ladies and gentle have Jon REEP
Institute what place you take on Last
Comic Standing
first you one last votes cast of last
call let's see second 2007 season 5
season 5 yes you want to hear the
rundown the the the lineup that year
yeah number one number two was uh God
who was number two I think it was Jerry
D Gerry Dee was Jerry D Canadian
comedian very funny dude yeah
no I'm sorry number two was Lavelle
Crawford oh [ __ ]
Lavelle Crawford how do you bad you beat
Laval Lavazza I thought Lavelle was
gonna win it but to me it was done he
was killing in the room no one could
beat Laval in the room but what would
turned out was at home it was different
people were voting differently but yeah
in crit was crazy
what makes a beast you know who's more
likable than a a black a fat black man
from the south a non racist white guy
but that's cool with the accent likewise
okay can I say this I might have said
Rice's racist put him up with something
I know what can I say this your Rice's I
thought I was a friend and you know if
they call out my mistakes oh my god is
the term because you know how Koreans
are like low-key really racist but your
rice is Rice's dude well some people
like yellow rice some people like brown
rice some people like white rice wha
what the Rice's you know you're not
really racist but you and I say well
Crawford came in number two
yeah number three was Jerry Dean um
before Amy Schumer oh my god that's not
sure what happened they would no no what
happened to her from her scent yeah I
was Ralph's gonna ask you something six
when something like that because I've
been let me just say something okay I've
been on MADtv right yes and you know I
like the time you know there's a couple
of guys on there that are like that bwe
blew up way
above me and they deserve it they're so
talented right okay but is there a part
of you that feels like because amy blew
up so big that you you you could I
always question like would it I didn't
do anything wrong life life is perfect
right my life is perfect the way it is
if if Mike Weir was any other way I
might not even like it I might kiss all
right this is the perfect life it but
you know the human condition you you you
you think you want more or what's better
on the other side do you feel I don't
blame anybody but myself that was my
fault I took my foot off the gas I was
like this is great I just want a bunch
of money
now I'm gonna tow like crazy make more
money why do I need to go do more press
I'm good
yeah just we'll coast for a while cuz
I'd do that okay I hit something hard
feels good
well let's enjoy this for a minute let's
live it up here let's enjoy it and then
it's like we need something else all
right I got a right new [ __ ] I'm not
ready I'm not ready I'm not and it does
this yeah I've always done that yeah so
I took my foot off the gas but and Amy
never did she I mean she just was like
let's go let's go all the way yeah and I
think she's used to she's very funny
she's very fun she's quick I love her me
too she was quick-witted she was always
the funniest one on the tour bus when it
would come to a quick comeback or Rio
off-the-cuff remark she was so good at
that
yeah fast at the time she was on the
show she was green as al she was she had
me doing stand-up that long you know a
couple years I have no we became friends
for a little while yeah yeah so still
friends of you sorry yeah yeah we're
friendly yeah we're friendly but yeah I
don't blame anybody for that yeah me
either